So Random Restart Hillclimbing is going to give us a way to deal with the fact
that hillclimbing can get stuck, and the
place where it gets stuck might not actually
be the best place to be. And so we can go back to that function
that we looked at before. So what are some places that this could get stuck?
>> There, there, and there.
>> And others to boot. So what randomized
hillclimbing's going to do is once a local optimum
is reached, we're just going to start the whole
thing again from some other randomly chosen x.
It's like, you know, sort of what you do
if you were trying to solve a problem and you
got stuck. You're like, okay let me just try to
solve it again. So why is this a good idea?
>> Hm. Well one it, it, it takes away the luck factor of I
happened to pick a good starting place. Although I suppose it replaces it with
the luck factor that I randomly happened to pick a good place. But that's
okay because I'm going to keep randomly picking
good places. Or randomly picking starting places
>> Yeah. So you get multiple tries to find
a good starting place. That there could be various places where
you start that don't do so well but as long as there's
places where you do well. Then you might luck into starting one
of those places and climb up to the tippy top and win.
>> Another advantage is that it's actually not much more expensive. So,
whatever the cost is, of climbing up a hill, all you've done
is multiply it by, you know, a factor, a constant factor, which
is how many times you are willing to do a random restart.
>> Yeah, that's a good way of thinking about
it. That it's, it's really just random hill climbing,
repeated how every many times you feel like you
have time to repeat it. And it can actually
do much, much better. Now, if there really is
only one local. Sorry, if there is only one
optimum and there is no local optimum, then what's
going to happen when we do random restart hill climbing?
>> We'll just keep getting the same answer.
>> Yeah, over and over again. So, could be that we, that we might
keep track of that and notice, okay, you know, what we seem in a space
where these random restarts aren't getting us any
new information. So, you might as well stop now.
>> Well, that's one answer but I could think of another answer. What's that?
>> So, maybe you just keep starting too close
to the same place you were starting before. I
mean, it may be random, but you can get
unlucky in random right? So, maybe you should make certain
your next random point is far away from where
you started, so that you cover the space. You
want to cover the space as best you can.
Yeah the randomness should do that, at least on average.
But you're right, so we could try to be more systematic.
So here might be an example of a kind of function where
that would be really relevant. So imagine we've got, here's our
input space and most of the random points that we choose are
all going to lead us up to the top of this hill.
But a very small percentage are actually going to lead us to the
top of the, the real hill. The top that we really want.
The optimum. So yeah, we, we might not want to give up after
a relatively small number of tries because it could be that this
tiny little, I know, I'm going to call it a basin of attraction.
>> Mm-hm. I like that.
>> And if it's small enough, it might take lots of tries to hit it. In
fact, it could be a needle in a
haystack. In which case, there's only one place that
you could start that has that optimum. And
that could take a very, very long time
to luck into. In fact, the hill climbing
part isn't doing anything for you at that point.
>> Yeah, but you know. If you're in a world where there's
only one point that's maximum. And, but there's only one way to get to it
by having to land on a single point. Then, you're in a bad world anyway. [LAUGH]
>> Right, I mean, there's going to be, nothing is going to
to work out. Nothing is going to help you in that world.
>> Yeah.
>> Right, and in fact, I would, I would
claim since everything has some kind of inductive bias.
Right you're, you're making some assumption about like local
smoothness or something. that, that makes sense here because if
you, if you are worried about a world where
there is always some point of the infinite number
of points you could be looking at say. That is the right one and there is no way
of finding it other than having to have stumbled
on it from the beginning. Then you can't make
any assumptions about anything. You might as well look
at every single point and what's the point of that.
>> Fair enough.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So the, the assumption here I guess is that
there, you can make local improvements and that local improvements
add up to global improvements.
>> Right. Hey I got a question. I got
a semantic question for you, a definition question for you.
>> Sure.
>> You decided that you didn't, if
you only had one optimum, you didn't want to
call it a local optimum. So, is a
local optimum, by definition, not a global optimum?
>> So, if I was being mathematical about it, I
would define local optimum in a way that would include the
global optimum but it's just awkward to talk about it
that way. because it feels like the local optimum is someplace
you don't want to be and the global optimum
is someplace you do want to be. But yeah
that's right the global optimum is a local optimum
in the sense you can't improve it using local steps.
>> Okay.